on this saturday night
the kovid 19 tax from the dentist
to the stylist the extra fees i think
it's outrageous to ask
something like this are canadian
consumers getting gouged the cautious
optimism about a vaccine breakthrough
never before have we dumped infinite
resources
into a vaccine development the potential
vaccine that could soon be tested
on canadians canada's aggressive
campaign
for a seat on the security council and
the rise in anti-asian crimes
this is the most disrespectful degrading
thing one human being can do to another
a new campaign to stop the hate
global national with robin gill
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us this weekend more canadians are
feeling a growing sense of freedom
many shops and restaurants are welcoming
back customers
after being shut down for more than two
months but they're facing higher costs
while
operating at reduced capacity under new
rules
as morgan campbell reports some
businesses are passing the buck
onto consumers on any given weekend
this place would be a buzz with clients
and salon chairs and chatter over blow
dryers
this is a regular surgical mask which
we're going to use
but in the time of covid there are no
regular business hours this toronto
salon is preparing to
reopen with a new business plan we're
not making any money off this
extended hours limitations on the number
of customers allowed
improved sanitization methods and a
barrage of personal protective equipment
and it comes with a price tag a three
dollar surcharge
we came up to the number because it pays
for the basic costs of what we're going
to use some businesses are tacking on a
covid surcharge as they navigate through
the pandemic kovid has hit retailers
hard
new data this week from statistics
canada shows about 40 percent of
retailers closed their doors
in march but not all customers are
willing to pay
a little bit extra why in the time where
their own clients are facing financial
uncertainty
would they put an additional charge on
to pay for their business costs
cassandra brown says she was going to be
charged an additional
10 dollars for her appointment says her
calgary dentist shoulders the cost of
ppe consumer experts say surcharges may
push customers away
if they do seek charges that should be
made known to the public so we can at
least have a choice whether to deal with
that company or not business experts
suggest not many will
implement a charge and for those who do
it'll likely be
a small fee i think that there are many
canadians that understand that small
businesses are struggling just like they
are
the canadian federation of independent
business conducted a survey
of its members which found that on
average business owners have lost
about two hundred thousand dollars since
this pandemic hits
robin morgan campbell reporting tonight
while more businesses are getting the
green light to reopen
canada's kovid 19 cases keep climbing
and the biggest spikes are still coming
from two provinces today quebec recorded
697 new cases and 75 more deaths
and the rate of infection continues to
rise in ontario
with 412 new cases today and 27 new
deaths
most new cases in that province are now
coming from community spread
the race is on around the world to
develop a coven 19 vaccine
but it is definitely a marathon not a
sprint
abigail beeman has an update on an
experimental vaccine with a canadian
connection
and other advancements around the globe
for the 124 groups racing to produce a
covid19 vaccine
there are three testing phases to work
through and a group with a canadian
connection just published positive phase
1 results
it looks to see if the vaccine is safe
in humans
and it also will look to see if people
can mount in an appropriate immune
reaction
to the vaccine that means you're given
the vaccine and then your body does what
it's supposed to do
it makes what's called antibodies that's
what happened with cannes sino
biologic's potential vaccine tested on
108 adults in wuhan china
in the coming weeks it will be tested on
canadians dalhousie university is a
partner
if all goes well the national research
council could produce
thousands of doses each week but that is
still a long way away
dr isaac bogash is optimistic there will
be a vaccine
eventually certainly i don't think it's
fair to compare the duration of time to
creating a covet 19 vaccine
from other vaccines because never before
have we dumped infinite resources
into a vaccine development this week the
u.s announced it would provide up to 1.2
billion dollars to drug company
astrazeneca
to fund a phase 3 trial testing 30 000
americans this summer
friday researchers at oxford university
announced they're ready to expand to
phase two
that vaccine would be manufactured in
india the serum institute is working
with half a dozen candidates
we're all in race to battle the disease
um you know there's no one-upmanship
here um
uh of course the sooner we get it the
sooner we can save lives and
uh you know that's all we're trying to
do here and scale it up as soon as we
can
and even though we're still a far way
off experts say it's not too early to
talk about logistics
it needs to be thought through because
what if the vaccine requires two doses
not just one to provide some degree of
immunity and what if the immunity only
lasts a year
and you have to re-vaccinate next year
like we do with flu
so a lot of logistics yet to be worked
out as well as a lot of
questions such as who would get it first
and what to do about people who don't
want to be vaccinated
abigail beeman global news ottawa
the house of commons is scheduled to
return on monday and tonight we're
getting a sense of how it may work
during the pandemic
the liberals have put forward a motion
proposing four hybrid meetings a week
plus a handful of summer sittings so
some mps will be in the room
others will join online the sittings
would also allow for
longer question periods
[Music]
on wednesday a bc supreme court justice
will rule on the case of mongonzo
the cfo of huawei is accused of
violating u.s sanctions
and the trump administration wants her
extradited to face charges there
the case has put a strain on canada's
relationship with china
because after her arrest two canadians
were detained in beijing
seen as a tit-for-tat our mercedes
stevenson joins us to talk about the
diplomatic acrimony
mercedes robin as the global community
reels from china's announcement that it
will impose a national security law on
hong kong
canada is still fighting its own
diplomatic battle with china
over the two canadian men michael spavor
and michael kovrig
who have now been detained for over 500
days by beijing
neither has been seen or heard from by
canadian officials
in over four months now last weekend on
the west block
china's ambassador to canada made a
clear link between the cases of the two
michaels and the arrest of mung wong
zhou the cfo of huawei
that clear linkage is a change in tone
for the chinese government
this week on the show we'll ask former
ambassador to china david mulroney
what he thought of the comments he made
no bones about connecting
the hmong joe case with the detention of
the two michaels
and i think what we're getting there is
the mask slipping china is now
no longer worrying about pretending that
there is some
you know legal reason for detaining our
two citizens
and they're showing both a power play
to intimidate us and they're showing
contempt frankly to canada and
into canadians and we're seeing this in
more of their
diplomatic um announcements and messages
but it's it's we're seeing the real
china in all of this
so just how does china see canada going
forward
as this country tries to negotiate the
release of our citizens
china sees canada as a vassal state of
the united states as a minor country
that it can push around and part of
their great anger at the mung wang zhou
process and the fact that um you know
she's facing extradition hearings
is china's outrage that a country as
small as canada
would dare to do this we'll also talk to
david mulrooney about the situation in
hong kong
and what canada should be doing to
respond plus we'll sit down with finance
minister bill morneau
and conservative leadership candidate
peter mckay robin
and you can see that all tomorrow on the
west block
with mercedes stevenson canada's
campaign for united nations security
council seat is in overdrive
the prime minister had several virtual
meetings last week with key voting
blocks
and more are on the way in the days
ahead the vote is next month and as our
david aiken is here to tell us it's a
50-50 bet as to whether
canada succeeds david
well robin there are two seats up for
grabs in the group of countries canada
belongs to but
there are three contestants canada
norway
and ireland norway and ireland started
their campaigns for the seat
years ago canada by contrast is late to
the game
and in a series of last minute pitches
prime minister justin trudeau
is emphasizing canada's status as a
middle power with a diverse
multicultural population we are big
enough
to make a difference on the council but
small enough to know that we can't do it
alone
our capacity to pull people together to
represent and reflect the diversity of
the planet
uh within our own population and make
that diversity and difference
a source of strength in the last seven
days trudeau has held
separate virtual meetings with
ambassadors from eastern european
countries
from the asia pacific region and from
arab states
the pmo has more meetings like that in
store with
other regional blocs in the week ahead
in doing so
trudeau is tying his own political
capital
to the outcome of the security council
vote
well i think the prime minister has put
his personal commitment to this file and
as a result
he's going to be the face of it no
matter what he's more popular abroad
although
right now he's quite popular at home as
well but he is still popular abroad and
therefore
his presence matters and is helpful in
these sorts of elections
trudeau believes the pandemic will
change the global order
in ways comparable to the period after
the second world war
when new international institutions were
created
and new alignments emerged so for him
that makes this security council
election
more vital than ever canada having a
voice at the u.n security council
will allow us to continue to be at the
heart of those discussions
as we move forward as a planet now
diplomats and government sources believe
that
norway is a lock to win one of the seats
and that right now it's a toss-up
between canada and ireland for the
second one
the vote is june 21st robin david aiken
in ottawa thanks david
in nova scotia about a thousand people
have been forced to leave their homes as
crews battle an out-of-control forest
fire
[Applause]
several crews have been working to
contain the fire since it ignited early
this afternoon
it has burned at least 40 hectares so
far at least three
aircraft have been brought in to douse
the flames fire officials say the dry
and windy conditions
are helping the flames spread in san
francisco a four-long fire ravaged a
warehouse on one of the city's historic
piers
flames lit up the pre-dawn sky as more
than 150 firefighters fought the blaze
on land and on the water the warehouse
which contained a fish processing plant
partially collapsed
firefighters were able to save a second
world war era ship which was docked at
the pier
it's a holiday weekend in the u.s and
crowds of americans are headed out to
beaches
parks restaurants and bars after months
of stay-at-home orders
there are concerns that will lead to a
new spike in
19 cases in the country hit hardest by
the pandemic
as jennifer johnson reports a new
research model predicts
a hasty return to normal may backfire
we just wanted to get a taste of
normalcy again and see what it's like to
be inside a business that's running
semi-normally at least temperature
checks for gamblers
more outdoor seating at restaurants
stricter cleaning at arcades
but the cdc is now downplaying the
transmission risk of covet 19 from
surfaces
while re-emphasizing the danger of close
human contact
one of the things we have to do is
really ensure that
customers are maintaining not playing
the game that's right next to another
player
and at the same time make sure our staff
wipes everything down the cdc has
estimated 25 to 50 percent of americans
could be asymptomatic and unknowingly
spread the virus
in some cities this weekend law
enforcement is busting places not
enforcing social distancing
like this san diego bar already forced
to close we simply cannot tolerate such
blatant and intentional violations of
the public health order
with more people out one research model
from imperial college london
based on cell phone data and not yet
peered reviewed
predicts the death rate could spike to 1
000 people a day by july in california
and florida
but white house experts are more
optimistic saying 42 states have less
than 10 percent of their populations
testing positive
please as you go out this weekend
understand you can go out
you can be outside you can play golf you
can play tennis with mark balls
you can go to the beaches if you stay
six feet apart
maryland washington d.c and virginia now
have the highest percentage of new cases
but the mid-atlantic beaches are open
another example of why health experts
are nervous about busy weekends like
this one
and the summer months to come jennifer
johnson
global news washington
ahead the troubles facing brazil's
president
crews have retrieved the black box from
that plane that crashed in pakistan
the first funerals were held today for
some of the victims two passengers
survived
at least 97 people were killed the pilot
told air traffic control he was having
engine trouble
just before issuing a mayday call one
survivor says the flight proceeded
normally until its descent
when there was a sudden jolt a
profanity-laced video of brazil's
president
is causing new controversy tonight
expresses frustration at his inability
to get information from police
he also vows to change cabinet ministers
if needed to protect his family
the supreme court ordered their footage
be released as part of an investigation
into allegations
the president was trying to interfere in
the federal police
for personal gain bolsonaro isn't taking
the covid19 crisis
seriously calling it a little flu but
the world health organization
disagrees and says south america is a
new epicenter
of the pandemic a number of countries in
that part of the world have seen a major
increase in cases
the change is in large part because
brazil overtook the united kingdom this
week
for third place in overall number of
coven 19
cases we've seen many south american
countries with
increasing numbers of cases and
and clearly there's a concern across
many of those countries but certainly
the most affected
is brazil at this point brazil now has
the fastest growth of infections
in the world there are more than 330
000 confirmed cases in the country and
more than 21 000 people have died from
the virus
but experts believe those numbers are
likely higher
because of a lack of testing still ahead
the campaign to focus on health
not hate
prime minister justin trudeau is calling
on canadians to stand up
and speak out against racism across the
country attacks targeting
asian communities have been on the rise
ever since the pandemic began
in vancouver alone 29 anti-asian hate
crimes have been reported
so far this year in 2019 only
four were reported in the same span
marking an increase of
600 percent global bc's john wall looks
at one group's solution
to filter out the hate we don't care
because
trixie ling teaches others what some
consider a taste of home
can be a bridge towards acceptance
for newcomers hoping for a new beginning
we really want to create this place of
not just acceptance but really belonging
but the founder of flavors of hope
recently became a target of hate
just one of a growing number of
anti-asian crimes
tied to the covet 19 pandemic as we got
closer
he then made some really direct sexual
and
racist comments at me and i just ignored
him that's when she says the young
caucasian male
spat in her face this is the most
disrespectful degrading thing one human
being can do to another
now the community is banding together
with a new campaign to counter
this hate i lived here my whole life
i've not encountered
a single incident of racism and now when
i go outside
i feel oh i need to be careful it starts
with a call out for public
figures to send in a simple photo those
pictures are then transformed
into a powerful statement i thought it
was so powerful
how they chose to use the masks for the
pandemic of course
and not turning a blind eye if you see
something say something if you hear
something do something
and it's not just community leaders and
celebrities that are being asked to join
anyone can take part in the social media
campaign
thanks to a new filter now launched on
instagram
and the message is clear during this
pandemic the focus should be on health
not hate so we cannot let the people the
few people who are doing this racist act
take over the story trixie ling is doing
just that
by taking a stand against racism some
worry has always been there
now just being pushed to the surface by
this pandemic
john hua global news
up next canada divided britain finally
come together
remember brexit seems so long ago now
but this june marks four years since
britain voted to leave the eu
that vote divided a nation now the
pandemic is the focus and as crystal
commansing explains
the health crisis has given the country
a new sense of optimism
at first glance it's hard to figure out
what's happening at this tiny shop
it's a music store but there are fresh
baguettes
and a friendly hello will get you an
offer of food
the store has become a hive of activity
kindly donated as the staging ground for
charitable operation mobilizing
volunteers
and food to feed those in need it's the
most incredible feeling
jenny mathias is energy in motion
ping-ponging from talking to packing to
getting crates of food loaded into cars
and onto bikes it's like christmas it's
like every day
we are we put ourselves in the position
to be hopefully father christmas to
everybody every day
the pandemic didn't stop food for all
the charity like many got busier but
there's also been a surge in desire to
help
at a time when people are struggling
sick and dying
brits are displaying their gratitude and
getting involved
69 percent of adults say britain will be
kind after the pandemic
the office of national statistics survey
found before kovitt 19
only 39 percent would say that and
56 percent thought post virus it would
be united
a jump from 19 percent it's one of the
most
unifying experiences i think i've seen
like in this country
especially coming out of an extremely
rocky period by that lauren spielman
means
brexit remember all of those emotionally
charged rallies and debates
i am currently on furlough as many
people are
and i am trying to do something
meaningful
with my fellow time this is the year of
compassion
this covid19 thing may be a bad thing
but it's also
it's also given us all everybody
involved in it which is everybody around
the world
a chance to observe their compassion
a bit of humanity when we all need it
the most
crystal gomansing global news london
well put that is global national for
this saturday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is our national
animal the beaver
having a nibble in a calgary park we'd
love to see your corner of the country
so send us your pictures
thank you for watching good night
[Music]